I had a good summer I don't know about
you guys I lost weight I'm very proud of
myself good for you well I mean I I had
my appendix removed is it true you had
your appendix I did it my appendix that
they were like we have to remove your
appendix and I was like can you get rid
of some of this other stuff look swollen
I don't even know what the appendix was
but you know like the doctor told me
that science doesn't even know what the
appendix exactly does and they're not
even sure why the appendix exists and I
was like oh my gosh the appendix is like
a Kardashian it's this mystery right
that that for some of us causes
excruciating pain has to be removed with
a knife yeah
I am not proposing violence against all
the Kardashians right just the mother
yeah now listen let's try and rein this
in you had your appendix I had my
appendix removed when I was about 12 and
at least was home but I we were on a
trip or saw with her I was in Alaska
with my that's not why I went there when
you want surgery get to Alaska get the
surgery and no it was I was just taking
to the closest hospital and the surgeon
who removed my appendix his name was
muffuletta doctor muffuletta which is
also the name of a New Orleans sandwich
so when he introduced himself I thought
am I being visited by the ghost of
Sandwich I realize I you know I don't
know what they do with the appendix
after they remove it and then I realized
I don't even know what meat is on a
muffaletta yeah a lot of mysteries so
you were in Alaska for you that's what
you've you got sick what will you do it
where I was there I had a show but I was
there on vacation with my family and
after the surgery was I was in and out
in like a day or so and then they sent
me back to my family not like it was
punishment returned to my family and the
only instructions they gave were that
they wanted me to walk a lot so I was
like perfect I'm in Alaska so we went
for a hike with the family and my kids
were screaming for no reason at all I
was pretending like I enjoyed being
outside
and then we saw this huge bear like 500
yards away it was like gigantic it was
like way bigger than a gummy bear my
wife and I we were so excited so we
started taking pictures and then the
bear stood up and roared and I was like
oh it didn't want its picture taken yeah
and then the bear kind of looked at us
and started creeping forward seriously
yeah like tilting his head like you
recognized us or something it's like did
I try and eat you before is that the guy
from Capote so you know we were
terrified so but luckily were with a
tour guide and he just looked at us and
he goes don't worry I have bear spray I
was like do you have anything stronger
like a bear gun because I don't know if
spray can stop a charging 600-pound
animal and then the tour guide
instructed us to walk backwards slowly
he was like walk backwards slowly and I
guess so the bear could catch up or
something walking backwards slowly
meanwhile the Bears in a full sprint
yeah and I had surgery 12 hours ago so I
smell delicious yeah that was also
sunburn so I probably look like a giant
land salmon I should point out it's not
like we were walking backwards to like a
car or a cabin we were walking backwards
to nothing it probably looked like we
were just teasing the bear like come and
gather
and it was crazy I was like I'm gonna
die by being eaten by a bear it's just
kind of ironic considering how many
animals
I've eaten I was like I was like oh this
is sorry I started saying the circle of
life and and then eventually the bear
ate us and we got wait wait okay I like
that was there with you all the way
until the very end where you're eating
and you die that's a true story that's
what happens eventually the bear just
turned round start running the other way
like you forgot something at home yeah
you